[Música]
la literatura juvenil es basura
qué lástima que recomiendas tantos
libros juveniles esos no sirven para
nada o mi favorito cuando vas a leer
libros de verdad y vas a dejar de leer
esa basura juvenil esos son algunos de
los muchos comentarios que me han
llegado a lo largo de los años que llevo
haciendo vídeos sobre libros en internet
por lo general elijo no responder los
pero si me he quedado con las ganas de
responder y dar una cátedra de porque
creo que la literatura juvenil es
importante y no como ellos y muchos
otros aseguran basura y ustedes podrán
pensar que cuando recibí la invitación
para dar esta charla yo pensé como o por
fin es mi oportunidad al fin voy a decir
todo lo que quiero decir pero no
la verdad es que hacer esto hablar en
público hasta hace algunos años estaba
en la lista de mis peores pesadillas de
la vida soy una persona muy tímida y
aunque con los años he aprendido un
poquito más a hablar con la gente a
comunicarme y hablar en público todavía
me cuesta y siempre voy a preferir estar
como encerrada en las paredes de mi
cuarto grabando vídeos con una cámara
indicaran antes eso también me aterraba
por lo mismo de que les digo que soy
bastante tímida pero tengo un lema de
vida y es que las pasiones siempre deben
deben ser tus miedos
entonces por eso fue que hace seis años
decidí tomar una cámara y hablar de lo
que más me apasiona que son los libros
entonces llevo todos estos años hablando
de libros en youtube semana tras semana
y es lo que más me hace feliz
a estas alturas creo que me he vuelto
una lectora bastante versátil y luego de
todo un poco pero si tengo que decir que
hay un tipo de libros al que suelo
acercarme más y esos son los libros
juveniles porque pues hay mil y un
razones pero creo que la principal es
que son los libros que cambiaron mi vida
literalmente cambiaron mi vida y la
siguen moviendo y cambiando
constantemente y como soy muy fan de las
historias y creo que las historias son
maravillosas les voy a contar la
historia de el primer libro juvenil que
me hizo sentir que no estaba sola y que
me lleno el corazón y ese es fangar the
rainbow robert es el libro yo lo leí en
el 2013
y trata de una chica que se llama cat
ella acaba de entrar a la universidad y
es súper tímida e introvertida y pues
desde ahí me identifiqué verdad la cosa
es que cat prefiere quedarse encerrada
en el dormitorio de la universidad antes
que ir a la cafetería a comer porque le
da pánico enfrentarse a este mar de
gente que está
cafetería y que ella no conoce y
recuerdo que yo estaba leyendo reseñas
de este libro y mucha gente decía como
como que la protagonista me pareció muy
poco realista y yo dije pues no porque
yo era así en la preparatoria y en la
universidad yo era exactamente así si yo
no estaba con mis amigos no me atrevía a
pisar la cafetería yo prefería quedarme
en el salón dibujando o leyendo con
hambre con mucha hambre pero yo no voy a
pisar esa cafetería entonces recuerdo
que cuando yo leí acá está está
protagonista y lo sentí como un abrazo
para esa clave del pasado que tenía
tantas inseguridades y tantos miedos y
pensé como wow como me hubiera gustado
leer esto cuando era una adolescente
porque me hubiera ayudado como no tienen
una idea pero luego lo pensé y me di
cuenta de que igual me ayudó porque me
ayudó a sanar a viejas heridas y creo
que ese fue el primer acercamiento como
importante que tuve
el gran impacto que puede causar un
libro en este caso fue la literatura
juvenil y lo padre tener este canal de
libros en youtube es que no solamente
cuento con mi experiencia sino también
con la experiencia de los jóvenes que
ven mis vídeos muchas veces me he topado
con jóvenes en ferias del libro o en
presentaciones que me dicen como oye yo
leí este libro por ti y fue un libro que
me hizo sentir que no estaba solo y en
el que me pude encontrar y cuando les
pregunto de qué o pues que el libro fue
por lo general me responden con algún
título juvenil y nunca se me va a
olvidar una vez que un chico de unos 14
o 15 años se me acercó y me dijo que el
encontró y leyó aristóteles y dante
descubren los secretos del universo por
benjamin al y de sants por una
recomendación en mi vídeo y que ese
libro lo salvó porque ese libro le hizo
darse cuenta de que no estaba defectuoso
de que sus sentimientos eran válidos y
de que estaba bien que un hombre
quisiera a otro hombre porque crearlo no
antes de leer ese libro él no había
hablado de sus sentimientos y sus
inquietudes
entonces ese libro lo hizo sentirse pues
que no estaba solo y que sus
sentimientos si eran válidos y siempre
que recuerdo su historia pues reiteró
que la literatura juvenil es importante
y después de esta me han llegado miles y
miles y miles de historias así
y antes de continuar quiero dejar en
claro que la literatura juvenil no es un
género como lo es la fantasía o la
ciencia ficción o el terror porque
muchos la tratan como género pero no la
literatura juvenil es más como una
etiqueta que se le da el libro al
momento de su venta es como una
categoría para saber el público objetivo
y el público joven fue un público que
estuvo ignorado por muchos años yo crecí
pensando que sólo habían libros
infantiles o libros para adultos o
clásicos y me era muy difícil encontrar
un libro que llamara mi atención porque
ni siquiera había una sección para
jóvenes en la librería y es que el
fenómeno juvenil tiene muy pocos años
así como tal las editoriales afirman que
empezó a raíz de que se publica bajo en
la misma estrella en el 2012
este libro ocasionó que se creara un
segmento en el mercado para la
literatura juvenil por su gran impacto
en ventas
no me dejarán mentir es tiempo en el que
los libros juveniles siempre están
encabezando las listas de ventas y eso
es porque los jóvenes estamos leyendo y
muchas personas todavía dicen los
jóvenes no leen pero solamente tienen
que ir por ejemplo a una feria del libro
los pasillos están repletos de jóvenes
muy emocionados gritando saltando porque
al fin consiguieron ese libro que tanto
buscaban o porque al fin consiguieron la
firma de ese autor que tanto querían
conocer entonces yo creo que los jóvenes
de verdad estamos leyendo mucho y se
refleja en las ventas de la literatura
juvenil y también me gusta incluir me en
este grupo de jóvenes aunque la realidad
es que ya no soy tan joven pero me gusta
repetirme una y otra vez que si lo soy
que si lo soy así pues ya yo solita me
la creo
y mencionó al público joven porque una
de las razones por las que se
menosprecia más a la literatura juvenil
es precisamente porque está dirigida y
pensada para jóvenes es como si todo lo
que los jóvenes consumieron fuera basura
porque obviamente obviamente todo lo que
le gusta a los jóvenes no sirve y peor
si le gusta a una chica adolescente y
esto es con sarcasmo yo no pienso eso
pero son cosas que he escuchado con los
años y que ya me están cansando yo
pienso todo lo contrario pienso que los
jóvenes somos inteligentes y apasionados
y que tenemos cosas importantes que
decir y que queremos encontrar historias
en los que nuestra voz se pueda ver
reflejada y eso es precisamente lo que
nos da la literatura juvenil y los
jóvenes no deben ser subestimados y los
autores que escriben juvenil lo saben y
lo demuestran en los textos que escriben
porque en los libros juveniles vemos
temas como política religión racismo o
incluso algunos muy difíciles y
sensibles
la salud mental el suicidio el acoso
sexual y también se le da voz a estos
grupos que han sido ignorados durante
muchos años como lo es por ejemplo la
comunidad lgtb y obviamente estoy
consciente de que no todos los libros
juveniles son buenos o de calidad yo no
soy quien para juzgarlos pero sé que
existen libros que sólo son para
entretenimiento y que no aportan nada
pero adivinen que también hay miles de
libros para adultos que no soportan nada
y que sólo son para entretener y ojo que
yo no le veo nada de malo a leer libros
para entretenerse y hay muchas personas
que dicen como no los libros solo deben
leerse para aprender que ok es válido
pero hay que tener en cuenta que la
gente puede leer lo que quiera y que
puede leer por las razones que quiera y
no está cool decirle a un joven oa un
lector nuevo que lo que está leyendo no
cuenta yo creo que deberíamos hacer todo
lo contrario deberíamos arreglar
alegrarnos de que cada vez haya más
gente leyendo más jóvenes leyendo y eso
es gracias a la literatura juvenil lo
curioso es que en mi caso
fue así como les dije yo crecí en una
época remota en la que los libros
juveniles todavía no estaban tan de moda
no eran populares y casi no existían en
el mercado o por lo menos no había como
este segmento destinado hacia ellos
entonces mi camino lector empezó con
libros infantiles y de ahí casi
instantáneamente me pasé a clásicos en
la secundaria y en la preparatoria leí
libros como la odisea las mil y una
noches' 'edipo rey' y me encantaron me
gustaron mucho pero también fue en esa
época que llegó a mi vida crepúsculo y
me volvió loca me encantó el primer amor
de mi vida fue el alcohol en pues del
vampiro brillante y no me arrepiento de
nada y recuerdo mucho que en ese tiempo
yo no estaba pensando como deshonra y
desgracia he bajado de nivel venía de
leer la odisea y ahora le y crepúsculo
no yo sólo estaba pensando que los
libros cualquier libro me hacía feliz y
leer historias me hacía feliz y eso
sigue siendo lo que pienso saben
creo que existe esta percepción errónea
de que los libros
populares son de mala calidad como si el
simple hecho de que estuvieran de moda
los hiciera malos y dicen ay es que los
jóvenes sólo leen por moda y eso es
aparentemente horrible cuando no debería
de ser así porque por ejemplo yo cuando
era chiquita me hubiera encantado que
leer estuviera de moda y así no hubiera
sido como la rara que se quedaba leyendo
a la hora del recreo en vez de salir a
jugar y si leer está de moda pues qué
moda tan bonita porque leer debe estar
al alcance de todos y no debe ser sólo
para como un grupo de intelectuales
todos debemos tener al alcance los
libros y a mí me da mucha risa que a
veces me llegan comentarios en plan de
que qué horror que leas tantos libros de
moda y yo no los respondo pero si los
respondiera solamente les preguntaría
cómo por qué y por qué creo que que leer
esté de moda es algo increíble qué
bonito que cada vez haya más clubes de
lectura en internet qué bonito que cada
vez haya más gente hablando de libros
book to bears que bonito y que increíble
que cada vez sea más páginas
dedicadas a libros y a sagas y me parece
maravilloso que en instagram existe el
hashtag books está gram y que haya
millones de publicaciones la semana
pasada revise y ahí vayan 39 millones de
publicaciones de libros de fotos de
libros entonces creo que eso es
maravilloso y pues también pienso que y
creo firmemente que la literatura
juvenil es valiosa y con esta charla no
pretendo hacer que todo el mundo cambió
de opinión simplemente quería salir a la
defensa de estos libros que me han
marcado a pesar de que no llegaron a mí
en mi adolescencia son libros que pues
siguen impactando en mi vida saben
porque están llenos de esperanza que eso
es algo que todos necesitamos están
llenos de enseñanzas y me recuerdan que
soy capaz de sentir a flor de piel son
los libros que más me emocionan y lo que
el arte busca es precisamente evocar
sentimientos y emociones y entonces
nadie me puede negar que la literatura
juvenil es arte
los libros juveniles son más que solo
historias para los lectores
los libros juveniles responden preguntas
como quién soy hacia dónde quiero ir en
qué creo en quién me quiero convertir y
me atrevo a decir que algunas de las
historias más valientes de la actualidad
están siendo contadas en los libros
juveniles tomemos por ejemplo el odio
que das de angie tomas este es un libro
que nos muestra la realidad del racismo
en la actualidad la protagonista es una
chica que tiene que ver como su mejor
amigo es asesinado brutalmente sin
justificación por un policía blanco solo
por su color de piel
ella vive esta brutalidad policíaca y
toda su familia y sus seres queridos le
recomiendan que no hable que se quede
callada porque es muy peligroso y ella
tiene que decidir pues entre
precisamente hacer eso quedarse callada
o buscar a justicia
este libro lleva 153 semanas
consecutivas en la lista de bestsellers
del new york times' y casi siempre está
en primer lugar porque porque es una
historia importante y que necesitaba ser
contada
y de este ejemplo quiero mencionar algo
que la literatura juvenil hace
constantemente habla de temas actuales
de temas que no podemos encontrar en
libros de años atrás se está
concentrando en los problemas en las
crisis en las situaciones que nos
estamos enfrentando en el ahora y en lo
que nos importa ahora ahora mismo en
nuestro mundo y creo que eso es muy
importante además en la literatura
juvenil hay mucha diversidad y
representación escribiendo juvenil hay
autores y autoras de color de la
comunidad el eje vete de con
discapacidades o con cuerpos que no
cumplen con los estándares de belleza
que se nos han impuesto desde los todos
los tiempos en la sociedad y estas son
personas que crecieron buscando
encontrarse en una obra de ficción y no
se encontraron entonces ellos ahora
están escribiendo libros contando sus
historias y eso es muy valioso y hacía
mucha falta además los libros juveniles
no son sólo para jóvenes hay muchos
adultos leyendo juvenil y el año pasado
fui a la bookexpo que es una feria libro
muy importante en nueva york
y una editora de eeuu me dijo que cada
vez había más adultos consumiendo y
comprando literatura juvenil adultos de
35 años 50 años incluso más grandes
porque son temas tan importantes y que
nos afectan tanto a todos no solo a los
jóvenes y si algo creo que tienen en
común todas estas historias en los
libros juveniles no es la trama que
siempre son muy variadas e increíbles
tampoco es por ejemplo la edad de los
personajes protagonistas que por lo
general sí pues varía entre los 15 y 20
años no lo que yo creo que estas
historias tienen en común es
que provocan cambios irreversibles en la
vida de los jóvenes que los leen son
libros que nos mueve y nos tocan en lo
más profundo que nos hacen sentir que es
lo más importante nos hacen pensar nos
hacen ver el mundo desde otra
perspectiva y nos ayudan a navegar en el
mundo actual en el mundo de la hora
y como diría benito taibo que es un
escritor mujer a quien quiero mucho los
libros juveniles nos dan educación
emocional que es la clase de educación
que todo ser humano debe tener para
sentirse vivo y si con algo quiero que
se queden de esta charla es que los
libros sin importar el género o la
categoría son magia los libros son casa
son amigos son aventuras y ya basta de
menospreciar a la literatura juvenil
basta de subestimar a los jóvenes y lo
que los jóvenes están leyendo porque la
literatura juvenil tiene libros
importantísimos y que están cambiando el
mundo ahora mismo ya lo están haciendo y
si no me creen a mí pregúntenle a
de los millones de jóvenes cuyo mundo ya
ha sido cambiado por una de estas
historias gracias
tú
[Música]